[Music]
this week a top-ranking Ukrainian senior
Commander said Ukraine could launch a
highly anticipated counter-attack very
soon as the battle for Bak moot rages on
and as Ukrainian troops try to regain
territory just outside of Kiev is a
Haven of Peace where some ukrainians are
using horses to de-stress from the
horrors of War Raymond ascencio has more
from Ukraine's capital
healing on Horseback the wounds of
Russia's war in Ukraine on children and
their parents not just physical but
psychological
Equine Therapy and animal therapy are
proven methods of managing trauma and
lowering stress
anastodnik and her four-year-old
daughter Maria fled their home in
harkhieve after Russia invaded
uh yeah it's difficult because she's
asking
every day why we are not living in hark
Hill I'm saying that we will come back
for sure but I don't know when
the war now 14 months in has displaced
millions of ukrainians breaking up
families forcing mostly women and
children to flee what's the one thing
that you tell her to try to make her
feel better
uh that Mama Mama is here with you
when she rode a horse
how did she react what did you see in
her uh she was she was more calm than me
for instance because I was stressful
because they chill for children it's
something very nice to communicate with
dogs with cats with horses Gana barago
is founder of Equine Therapy Center
Spirit Warrior
people that come here feel as if they've
gone back to their childhood animals
can't criticize they can't judge it
gives people a chance to be at one with
themselves
says more than 5 000 children have come
here for mental healing redirecting
their trauma and re-centering themselves
through touch and care
nearly 300 service members have come
here too some with skepticism anger and
post-traumatic stress disorder
it's much harder with the military and
the men keep their emotions bottled up
they're on rotation from active War
zones then go back to fight
Elena opaleva and her daughters Veronica
and Amelia have been displaced twice
since 2014. you brought your two
daughters how were they affected by the
war
they're always nervous and emotional
it's hard to handle for them when the
air raid sirens go off our youngest
Amelia starts to scream was today a good
day for you
yes they say it was a good day
then Veronica starts to sing
[Music]
not a song about war but about love
a few moments of cheer where everyone
feels all right in the company of gentle
Giants that help heal the mental wounds
of War for CBS Saturday morning Remy
inocencio Kiev Ukraine